Eero my name is Sammy and I'm from Ali
fall originally from Atlanta Georgia
from Sydney Australia
London England local Russia there's been
a lot more but those ones were coming to
mind my name is Sammy grant I'm a
dialect coach and I'm legally blind a
[Music]
dialect coach is someone who teaches
actors accents I can do accents from
around the world I don't really even
have a count anymore because I've taught
so many I mostly work for this stage
I've started dabbling in television one
of the reasons I think that I took to
voice work and dialect work is because
I'm more in tune with hearing so people
are always like oh you a peyten hearing
I don't like that phrase because it
sounds like we have some like superhero
hearing like weird daredevil or
something or you're just like daredevil
no but I do have more tuned sharing I
used my hearing more than a sighted
person because I have to fill the London
accent basement is really important so
placements like really forward in the
mouth so there's the southern accent
that lacks we are the Australian accent
quite different than fresh accents so
they don't really say like but ah with a
more light but a transatlantic accent a
very dramatic it's would have here in
the whole time movie it's kind of like a
well why don't know was he ever going to
love me well I did want to love me what
if I'm too expressive maybe he won't I
don't know what Russia makes me want to
sort of feel like you slows down and
vicars women this is a very stereotyped
word like the Jewish New York mother
this is why I do a lot with my friends
you know kind of like the why don't you
call me you know I I sit around away a
few calls all day you never call me I
don't mind okay just whatever it's
basically a college tuition it's okay
it's a pretty in-depth process teaching
someone in accent I get sent this script
and I try to gather everything I can so
that goes much beyond just where does
this take place
it also factors in time period and
education level class level and I also
think about the gender of my characters
and then I talk with the director to
sort of you know touch based on their
concept for the voice of the show and
then I kind of go on a hunt for
authentic speakers once I've gathered
all that information I present it to the
actor
we're now surrounded by so many voices
that are emotionless you know by these
automated voices that sound very fake
worth like I'd love to help you I'm a
computer that's here to help you with
whatever you want all the time I love
meeting new people and hearing their
voices I you know immediately go into
dialect coach mode and I want to sort of
imitate them I just want to like
experience their voice and experience
with their vocalizing
[Music]